so today I want to tell you a problem
that was devised by a Hungarian
mathematician called Paul Tron and this
was something he noticed when he worked
in a forced labor camp in World War II
he was actually forced to work in a
brick making factory his job is you had
the Kilns right that's making the bricks
and then he would have to load the
bricks onto a trolley
and then he would run that trolley on
tracks and take it to the storage units
so you could just run these bricks to
and from the storage units the only
problem was when these tracks crossed
because when they crossed the trolleys
had a habit of jumping the tracks and
spinning the bricks right oh no right
what a disaster so it did make him think
how can we make these tracks or how can
we design this brick making factory so
we can minimize the number of Crossings
uh so that's our problem for today this
is the brick Factory problem all right
so we've got Kilns and storage units
let's do one Kiln and one storage unit
just to keep it simple so that's not
going to be a problem is it so that's
just going to be a track connecting the
Kiln to the storage unit not a problem
at all what if we had uh one Kiln and
two storage units doesn't sound like
it's going to be a problem either does
it and then yes we can just run a track
and we want to connect the Kiln to every
storage unit that's the idea let's say
we had two Kilns and two storage units
maybe that's a little bit more
interesting maybe you had a kiln here
and a kiln there and two storage units
now we want to connect every Kiln to
every storage unit so that would have to
connect that would have to connect that
would have to connect maybe you can see
I've got a crossing point here so if I
went to complete it I'll just do it I'm
going to have a crossing point so what
do you think what could we do to solve
that problem so so we could have our
Kilns and storage units like before we
could start to connect them like this
and then instead of crossing the tracks
maybe I'll just do a loop
that would solve the problem or as
another solution maybe I could just put
my Kilns and storage units in a bit of a
circle like this Kiln storage Kiln
storage then I can connect everything
together in a loop like that now it's
another way to solve the problem the
first interesting example will be three
Kilns and three storage units so let's
take a look at that looking at these
together so far so good but then we're
going to start getting into problems I
think so I need to connect to the second
storage unit and I connect to the third
storage unit I think I'm going to start
getting tracks that are crossing and I'm
going to get an answer like this I think
I have M7
Crossing points right oh what a disaster
you don't want seven crossing points
you'll be picking up bricks all day
right
how could we solve that
come about I don't know best solution I
can think of put them in a circle let's
try that Keon storage unit alternating
in a nice hexagon but we can connect
these up in a nice easy Loop can't we
okay so now we've got six of the lines
there's three more to connect
essentially I need to connect the Kilns
the storage unit that's opposite on this
hexagon uh so let's do this one first
that's a nice easy one to connect this
Kiln to this storage unit I don't want
to cross that track I can go the long
way around nothing wrong with that and
now this Kiln to this storage unit
opposite and I will get stuck here I
will have to cross which is fine if I go
on the outside I am going to have to
cross the track or if I go on the inside
I'm going to have to cross one of the
tracks I hope that convinces you that I
can't do it without crossing a track but
I can do it with one one Crossing so
that kind of minimizes the number of
Crossings and how can we do this in
general
right so if you've got let's say k Kilns
an S storage units
um how can we arrange our Factory so
that we can minimize the crossings
you might want to have a think about it
but I have an answer for you I can show
you a nice picture that does solve this
let's have a look so what you want to do
is we're going to try and kind of draw
it
uh like a like a graph with an x-axis
and a y axis
I guess a kiln axis and a storage unit
axis so like this a horizontal and a
vertical I'm going to put the Kilns on
the horizontal axis and I'll try and do
half on the left and half on the right
or if it's an odd number which is fine
I'll do as close as I can to half and
half let's say I got six so I put three
on the left and three on the right so
that's going to be my Kilns like that
and the storage units I'll put on the
vertical axis and this is how I'd lay
out the factory we're going to avoid
the origin right there in the middle
that's where we're avoiding no Kilns no
storage units there let's say I do M5
just to show you the odd number version
of this as well so five I'll do three
out above and two below yeah one two
three and two below so I'm claiming that
this is a minimum uh let's take a look
let's see what Crossings we're going to
get I'm going to take this Kiln by Keon
I'll just work my way on the left hand
side here I think so let's do this first
kill and I'll uh connect these three
storage units up here no problem so far
let's do the second kill I am going to
get crosses here I'll do this count to
the first storage unit I'm gonna get two
crosses and connect to that storage unit
connect to the second storage unit I've
got one cross and then if I connect to
the third storage unit that's not a
problem and get all the way up so so far
I've got three I'll do the final Kiln as
well we're gonna get quite a few crosses
here let's try and work it out I'm going
to connect to the first storage unit one
two three four four crosses and to the
next one one two and connect and then to
the one at the top that's not a problem
I can just connect so I've got another
six there so I've got nine crosses all
together so I'm gonna get nine on this
side as well when I connect these three
Kilns so on the bottom we're gonna get
three and we're gonna get three down
here so all together how many crosses
are we going to get uh nine plus nine
plus three plus three twenty four well
I'm claiming that's a that's the best
you can do 24 crosses uh it's certainly
that's what we believe that's the best
you can do it's actually not been proven
that that's the best but we haven't
found an answer that can do better
uh we can also write this down out as a
formula so you don't have to draw the
whole thing so if you want to work it
out you can work this out as a formula
same sort of thinking the way I showed
you how it works if you work it out as a
formula looks like this Z is the number
of crosses let's say k Kilns s storage
units then the formula looks like this K
divided by two if it's an odd number you
can round that down multiplied by K
minus 1 divided by two if that's an odd
number you can round that down and
multiply that by S divided by 2 which we
can round down and S minus 1 divided by
2 which we can round down so there's
symmetry in this I guess there's no
difference really between the Kilns and
the storage unit not from a mathematical
point of view so you can see the
Symmetry in there we can just double
check our result let's do it and what
did I have six kills five storage units
so that's going to be six divided by two
we might have to round that down that's
going to be 5 divided by two and round
that down storage units five storage
units so that's now a five divided by
two round that down and four divided by
two round that down uh well six divided
by two is just three multiplied by this
is 2.5 we round it down to two same here
2.5 rounded down to two and this here
that's just two that's fine three times
two times two times two is twenty four
which is the answer we've got so that is
a Formula that describes this picture we
think that's the minimum not proven but
it does mean that your number of crosses
if you're in this situation with your
Kilns and your storage units it's going
to be this number or smaller we know
that much so it's this number or better
we think that's the minimum I can't
believe people aren't all over this one
I can't believe it's not like been
cracked yeah so they did think they
proved this at one point and that was a
proof that people accepted for 11 years
is one of those stories when they go oh
yeah that seems right until someone
noticed a mistake we know this much so
this minimum number of crosses it's
gonna be less than my little formula and
83 percent of that so we're whittling it
down we're sandwiching it between these
numbers we're getting there we're
starting over trying to hone in on that
number it has been proven for some
numbers so it's been proven for uh
number of Kilns less than or equal to
six and storage units as many as you
like so arbitrarily many storage units
and six Kilns or less we know that is
the minimum so that has been proven or
vice versa because it's all symmetric if
you want to do it the other way around
but for any values no we haven't proven
that that's the minimum yet
and there is applications for this apart
from building bricks yeah you want to
use this kind of idea when you're making
computer chips so you've got your
circuitry and your computer chip and you
don't want them Crossing you want to
minimize those crosses because every
time those circuits cross you have to do
that in a new layer so that they those
circuits don't cross so it's important
when making things like that it might be
worth talking about
um complete graphs as well a complete
graph is the idea where you have these
dots
they're not Kilns and storage units
anymore and they're just dots and you
want to connect everything to everything
else so if I had like five dots in a
pentagon and I will connect everything
to everything else first of all I can
just connect my Pentagon up and then
connect all the other lines I haven't
done yet so that's called a complete
graph because you've connected
everything to everything that's got five
Crossing points on it
can we minimize that same question so
can we minimize that yeah you can
so we could have the high uh five dots
in a pentagon like that and we can draw
that out as a pentagon as well so let's
do our other lines so we could have one
line there and we could have one line
there uh I think we could have one line
sort of going out on the outside like
that one line going on the outside like
that and what am I missing
this point to this point I'm missing and
I have to cross
yeah so I do have to cross at one point
so that's me minimizing the number of
Crossings so I can get it down to one so
the question is how do you do that in
general and that's connecting everything
to everything we think we've got an
answer to that as well it's really nice
answer actually uh let's I'll do the
sixth version for this so for if I
wanted to connect everything to
everything for six you draw it as a
regular polygon so I'm going to draw a
hexagon out I then draw in my edges
there you go and now I need to draw in
the remaining lines this is the rule if
the slope is positive it goes on the
inside of the polygon so positive slope
I mean something like this that has a
positive gradient okay it's sloping
upwards this line has a positive
gradient so it stays on the inside and
this line has a positive gradient it
stays on the inside oh and I should say
this line is also positive going
vertically up and this line going
vertically up is also positive as well
if your line is zero or negative it goes
on the outside so this point to this
point would be negative a negative
negative slope so I'm going to draw it
on the outside instead like that and
this point to this point would be
negative so I'm going to draw that on
the outside as well this point here to
this point so I've only got one line
left it's this point connecting to this
point
which would have been your zero and
that's going to have to cross on the
outside
there how many crosses do we have three
actually there's two there on the inside
and then there's one there on the
outside and that again
is what we think is the minimum number
of Crossings for that uh you can write
that out as a formula as well so if you
just have end points connecting
everything to everything for this
diagram this is how many crosses it has
it is one quarter of and then we do a
rounding down of n divided by two round
down n minus one divided by two round
down n minus two divided by two round
down and minus three over two like that
I did six here didn't I quarter of
uh six over two rounding down five over
two
rounding down four over two
and three over two
and so it's gonna be a quarter of
three times that's gonna be two that's
gonna be a two and that is one and a
half rounded down which is a one which
is going to be yeah three which is
exactly what it should be so that
formula is describing that picture and
we think that's the minimum
again it's the same problem we haven't
found a drawing that is better so we
think that's the minimum and that's
useful to know because that's kind of
your worst case scenario because it's
everything connecting to everything else
so if you've got a graph which doesn't
connect everything to everything else
it's going to be that value or smaller
than that value so it's worth knowing
that as well we have proven that it is a
minimum for n less than or equal to 12.
so we do know it's a minimum for that
but for the other numbers still a
conjecture
if you enjoy learning stuff here on
number file well you're gonna love
brilliant they're custom made courses
questions and quizzes will expand your
mind and bring a few smiles to your face
as well everything's so interactive
meaning you don't just look at a screen
you get Hands-On with the material and
there's no better way to learn than that
I don't just enjoy the knowledge on
brilliant I like that it has a bit of
Personality sometimes it's quite funny
this course on math history well it's a
favorite of mine
and by the way brilliant has a 30-day
free trial so you could go and do this
course right now and if you do sign up
to their annual premium subscription
there's a 20 discount by visiting
brilliant.org number file it's never too
late to learn something new check out
brilliant there's also a link in the
video description
for us to be all related to the same
ancestors now you were saying
this is not true to life and I agree
this is not true to life because in this
example I'm just as likely to have two
parents who are from Paris